big news the United Kingdom of course
yesterday Prince Harry and Megan Marco
welcomed their first child a baby boy
that's exciting now now they haven't
named him yet as it's a tradition in the
royal family to wait a couple of days
and inform the queen of the name before
anybody else so guess what we've started
a little royal baby naming pool here at
the show can I have a take a look at the
list thank you very much I've got a lot
of good guesses here I guessed Henry
because it's such a traditional royal
name and Andy its sister you had Spencer
yeah Spencer's Princess Diana's maiden
name I thought they might want to honor
her that's pretty cool yeah that's a
good guess all right anyone else who
hasn't thrown in a name yet what about
you big Paul big Paul Junior
I'm just gonna put down Paul okay all
right how about our prop master built Oh
what do you think Bill Michelle yeah
it's it's a it's a boy Bill Michelle was
a he's a girl's name it can be both
[Applause]
okay scares the [ __ ] out of me
fine anybody else Jerome our sound
engineer what do you think Bongo
you panic didn't you yeah okay yeah all
right all right well anyway let's go
over here what about our Tony the
cameraman trusty cameraman Tony what's
what's your guest for the royal baby's
name well as you know I am a lifelong
Anglophile and royal family fanatic
didn't know that at all I never had such
I have thought long and hard about this
very question that has vexed the world
and I have determined that without a
doubt the new royal baby's name will be
jetpack laser penis jetpack laser penis
you think they're gonna name an heir to
the British throne jetpack laser penis
it's a Bible name I I doubt that very
much
okay call Richter Tony take it easy now
put two hun
I'll put down jetpack laser penis but I
I think you're just throwing your money
away okay
fine now you know what I would very much
like to change my guest then okay very
good good good thinking there Tony
whoo jetpack laser penis the third
alright fine I just put down jetpack
lazer penis the third alright I think
that's everyone what's that they're
making it you're kidding really Jeff
that's crazy Jeff just signaled to me
and that signal told me that the Queen
of England is about to announce the name
of the new Royal baby this is very
exciting
Billy can you go to the feed from
Buckingham Palace so close
well sorry Tony but you didn't guess
jetpack laser penis the fourth so looks
like nobody want you guys guys guys
we show that kid you can put it down now
Jeff that's horrifying that picture we
put up is the fakest looking thing oh no
very little work went into that piece
don't worry about it